moi je débats en france au royaume l
année dernière je n'ai pas vu donc les
événements j'ai vu dans les journaux le
spa est ce que vous pouvez me dire ce
qui se passait quelques manifestants
mais il n'y a pas eu de faute grave ne
se passe jamais rien
[Musique]
comment c'était
mais
[Musique]
à
c'est une manifestation devant donc la
sécurité sociale avec monique nous à
jacques boutault nif un joueur connu les
copains quoi on était le tous ensemble
oui je suis en train de monter la
justice est rendue à barbiche vidal
hélas hélas oui je suis de dollars je
crois que je me rends compte maintenant
je crois que j'étais la seule femme au
président au niveau des assemblées
générales de province je crois qu'il a
sion une ville devenue très nombreux je
crois nous les étudiants on croyait pas
forcément quand vous pensez pas que ça
allait se mobiliser autant quoi c'est ça
a été peut-être la première surprise
c'est de voir que tous ces jeunes les
étudiants tout le monde les lycéens tout
le monde venait en fait à nos
manifestations
les ouvriers nous ont rejoint donc ne
pensait pas qu'il y avait autant de gens
qui avaient envie de protester
j'ai dit bois l'intervention du 13 mai
je veux bien la faire tout en toute
inconscience c'était ma première
intervention
j'avais quand même que 21 ans
les copains m'ont dit tu sais bien ok
vas-y tu t'inquiètes pas toutes façons
orléans c'est une ville bourgeoise quand
il ya 15 cents ou 2000 personnes dans la
rue c'est une révolution est finalement
sur sur la place de gaulle là bas on a
vu la rue des carmes boucher
complètement par les manifestants la rue
j'ai perdu le nom qui rejoint la place
du martroi bouchés par les manifestants
et on les a évalués ils ont été évalués
à l'époque à 10000 personnes à orléans
[Musique]
c'est bon
mais
nos camarades étudiants lycéens et
enseignants travailleurs si nous nous
retrouvons aujourd'hui dans cette
manifestation
ceci montre bien que le mouvement lancé
par les étudiants et celui lancé par
l'ensemble des travailleurs ne sont pas
deux mouvements parallèles au contraire
nos actions se rejoignent la lutte que
nous menons étudiants enseignants
lycéens pour la démocratisation et de
même nature que celles menées par les
travailleurs pour la démocratisation
dans l'entreprise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rapidement j'ai quitté la fac et je suis
allé je suis allé dans les usines et ce
qui était intéressant c'est que on
arrivait à 3 ou 4 devant une usine on
expliquer le mouvement et les les
ouvriers des usines de 2 300 personnes
se mettaient en grève
il ya une dame plus vieille voie après
qu'on ait fait la tête jusqu'aux pu
apprendre discuter avant tout ça c'était
quand même bon enfant elles ne voient
avec du café une cafetière et me dis
tiens mon gaza nous ça nous fait du bien
que vous soyez là est bien mais qu'a
fait elle me donne une pièce de 5 francs
c'était des grosses pièces je m'en
souviendrai toute ma vie elles étaient
toutes brillantes comme si elle l'avait
astiquer et me dit voilà vous vous
causez pour nous
on a vu l'une après l'autre les
entreprises se fermer 1
la première je crois de mémoire et l
usine d'ambert enfin une elec à saint
jean de braye ou à l'ats le patron a été
carrément enfermé 1
ça a commencé comme ça j'ai une anecdote
parce qu'un jour au piquet de grève des
chèques postaux dans la rue du grenier à
sel on voit arriver on voit arriver
petite équipe de femmes et disent aux
gens du piquet de grève
ben on est nous dans une petite
entreprise textile dans la rue porte
madeleine
j'ai perdu le nom de cette entreprise
mais bon c'était un petit atelier et
puis ben on a enfermé le patron mais
maintenant on sait plus quoi faire alors
il faut venir nous aider donc bien
évidemment les copains melon mais me les
ont envoyées et puis on a discuté avec
ces femmes qui nous ont raconté leurs
conditions de travail etc
et puis on leur a dit bah c'est simple
vous allez prendre un cas un papier un
crayon puis vous allez écrire toutes vos
revendications
et donc on a bâti un cahier de
revendications cas était alors on les a
emmenés négocier avec le patron qui a
accepté d'ailleurs une grande partie de
leurs de leur demander et on leur a dit
maintenant si vous voulez maintenir les
choses
gardez un moyen de contrôler la solution
celle syndicats
j'avais cette caméra j'avais fait du
site du film et puis j'y tiens parce que
j'y tiens je vais filmer
si jamais ça depuis comme personne n'a
pris de photos une personne a pris des
photos
j'étais pas responsable syndical à cette
époque là nous suivions tel à telle les
moutons de panurge nos dirigeants
syndicaux ça s'est passé en toute
honnêteté à la bonne franquette
il n'y a pas eu d'accroc jamais durant
le séjour de la derrière on n'a jamais
eu une prise de bec jamais diorite
heures il était avec nous aussi tout où
c'est vraiment très bien passé
[Musique]
on avait des grèbes à rien oasis était
relativement calme dans une bagarre
shaul la terre peut s'écrouler orléans
resterons calmes il s'agit de 150
entretiens qui ont été faits à la fin
des années soixante huit et en 69 par
des universitaires franco-britannique
qui faisait une étude sur le français
parlé
donc vous avez des ouvriers vous avez
des professeurs d'université vous avez
des médecins vous avez les employés etc
qui aurait qui ont tous raconté comment
ils ont vécu mai 68
orléans rien fait que le vide bourgeois
la plupart des organes et raconte qu'il
ne s'est rien passé orléans quand on
leur pose la question et mai 68 à
orléans
la plupart des réponses sais rien en
creusant un petit peu en écoutant un peu
plus les réponses on se rend compte
qu'ils expliquent que toutes les usines
étaient fermés qu'il y avait des défilés
dans la ville qu'ils ont eux mêmes fait
grève comme la plupart des gens autour
d'eux qu'il y avait un grand
bouleversement mais c'est ce qu'ils
appellent très calme être rien la vision
qu'ils ont des événements de mai 68
c'est ceux donnés par les médias et qui
racontent qu'ils écoutent et normalement
la radio et que ce qu'on entend à la
radio
c'est une révolution à paris
c'est des voitures qui brûlent c'est des
barricades c'est des bagarres qu'ils
puissent beaucoup le mot bagarre
le faire de grandes étapes sont égaux
mais enfin bon sens fieschi or qu'est ce
qu'il va faire dans la rue fils quand je
suis allé faire la révolution
[Musique]
mais ça fait si bon sang de bon sang je
te donne plus qu'en basse et d'argent
contre la société de consommation au
total les ter n'arrive plus les surcoûts
et d'autres proposent ce qu'ils ont vécu
en direct en tant qu'acteur à orléans
qu'il qualifie de calme à ces images
qu'ils ont de de paris et de des
événements qui se sont passés à paris
ici les trois cas les quelques étudiants
du cru devoir se faire les malins quand
c'est tout on avait eu parce qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de rumeurs en mai 68 et voilà
donc on a une rumeur qui nous dit va
peut-être y avoir une attaque du campus
donc on s'est dit qu'est ce qu'on va
ainsi regrouper on était trois de l'unef
on s'est regroupé on s'est dit on va
attendre une heure du matin il s'était
rien passé on s'est dit on va se coucher
quand on s'est couché voilà et donc là
moi je suis réveillé en sursaut
donc par quelqu'un qui rentre dans ma
chambre armée et qui me dit habillez
vous habillez vous et vous allez
descendre
il me dit les mains en l'air et ils nous
disent vous aller nettoyer la
bibliothèque alors nettoyer la
bibliothèque ça veut dire quoi c'est que
nous avions protéger la bibliothèque
nous les militants voilà de l'époque
parce qu'on avait tout recouvert pour
protéger les livres et puis à un moment
donc ils nous ont dit maintenant les
filles vont sortir
voilà donc on est sorti maintenant les
gars on est là dans les garçons ils ont
gardé trois militants de l'unef et là là
je me suis dit oh là là ça va mal se
passer pour eux un qui était dans ces
gens donc on avait des gens qui étaient
avec nous en fac de droit qu'on
connaissait un peu comme des fachos faut
le dire on avait des militaires des gens
qui étaient en parachutistes et puis
d'autres gens il y avait deux japonais
qui ont été très sérieusement frappés
par ce que parce que je pense que les
paras revivez peut-être un peu des
combats qu'ils avaient mené contre des
asiatiques quoi c'est c'est eh c'était
ce à quoi on a en a pensé à ça nous on a
pensé à ça c'était ces petits c'était un
commando de hier qu'on avait nous on en
était
on comprenait pas qu'on comprenait pas
ce qui se passait sans doute les veines
le plus importante
de ce mois
mais 2 ou 3 juillet tout est terminé
tout le monde est parti il ya eu donc
les commandos à la fac il ya une
perquisition chez moi tu es dénoncer je
pense que ce qui se cherchaient et ils
m'ont pris j'avais plein d' affiches des
beaux-arts et puis des journaux je
partais en angleterre je pensais à
l'ailé parce que je veux pas beaucoup de
sous je pensais les vents de la base
d'une saine tradition et m'ont tout
piqué il ya une chose qui
rétrospectivement m'a fait peur mon père
comme il est artisan étaient copains il
d'autres artisans et des copains avec un
peintre qui est toujours vivant il à 94
ans là et il est toujours à châteauneuf
ai dit écoute ton fils et les copains
fous qu'ils arrêtent de
je crûment il faut qu'ils arrêtent de
faire les cons parce qu'il lui faisait
partie des anciens réseaux de la
résistance qui a vu une résistance un
maquis de loris etc
il était resté gaulliste et 10 en
sologne les cavs sont prêtres si ça
continue dans une semaine on les ramasse
et on les mène dans les caves
[Musique]
on ça va être la fin allait avoir lieu
puisque les façons on se fait chier à la
langue
alors donc ils étaient les rangs s'est
donc offert ça pour prédire les
sanaryens qui était la chance de
s'asseoir nationalisa mais il s'était
fait des chapeaux en papier
et puis le directeur est venu et puis
c'est un soleil qui a ouvert la porte
avec lui le patron
monsieur ghosn eric en l'occurrence il a
ouvert la porte à gagner d'un salarié
les paires précités fini et on est
rentrés chacun chez soi alors qu'ils
enlèvent la fuite ch
[Musique]
voilà
le rêve est fini